AND THIS ONE IS UNDERWAY. THE LY
TROUBLE.
>> Dennis: AN INTELLIGENT
PLAYER
JETS TO PLAY EVERY GAME SO FAR
THIS SEASON.O
HORVAT IS OUT.
>> Dennis: ANDREW COPP TO THE
HUNT LET'S THE SHOT GO, AND
CONNOR HELLEBUYCK TRACKS IT DOWN
AND WILL HANG ON TO IT.BACK FORE
FORMER CANUCK AND HE'S OF THE ZD
NOW A LOW TO HIGH PLAY.
A HITONED
CONFIDENCE WITH SVECHNIKOV,
ANOTHER SAVE WITH MARTIN, PUCK
IT LOOSE AND BOUNCES TO THE NEAR
SIDE.
KYLE C C CONNOR RIPPED IT OFF
THE LEFT ARM O HIS PASS
INTERCEPTED, CAME TO THE SIDE OF
THE NET AND PUNCHEDITS PER
GAME WITH 1,421.
THE VANCOUVER CANUCKS BY MINNESA
FOR COACH BRUCE BOUDREAU.
CANUCKS BY THE AND
TYLER MOTTE, FORMER UNIVERSITY
OFLOOKING FOR THE STICK OF KYLEM
THEY GET TO ORDER, FROM HIGH ICO
WELL SPOKEN.
IT'S REFRESHING TO HEAR HIM
TALK.
A PLAY THAT WOULD HAVE BLOWN
COPP, SPENCE BEAULIEU OFF THETHT
.
48 POINTS GOAL, FOUR POINTS.
EIGHTEENTH CAREER TWO-GOAL GAME,
BY THE WAY FOR J.T. MILLER WHO'Y
SPENCER MARTIN.
>> Kevin: THERE'S'STHER NIGHT.
>> Kevin: I LOOK UP TO THE,
DENNIS.
SPENCER MARTIN.
I'LL GETL LEAVE IT BY
J.T. MILLER THAT'S VANCOUVER UP
2-1.
SHIFT, THE JETS HAVING NOTHING
BUT CHANCES, FOR THE
THIRD PERIOD, VANCOUVER UP A
SCORE PASS FROM SCHEIFELE
TRYING TO SEND THE CAPTAIN
AND A STICK RIDES UP, ANDNNNNNNN
.
PLAY AS PIONK BATTLELE
AND POGANSKI UP THE BOARDS OUT
AT CENTRE FOR JANSEN HARKINS.
ON IT GOES